Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, estoy convencido
de que no voy a tener que hacer ningún esfuerzo
para convenceros de que Latinoamérica es
una de las regiones más inseguras y convulsas
del mundo.
Desgraciadamente, la violencia y el crimen
han hecho que algunas zonas de Latinoamérica
sean un lugar peligroso.
Hablamos, todos lo sabéis, de una región
ha sido fuertemente golpeada por el tráfico
de estupefacientes, el tráfico de armas y
otras tantas actividades ilegales que se han
desarrollado sin que los estados hayan podido
[O hayan querido, tampoco nos engañemos]
poner remedio a esa situación.
Aunque sea algo difícil de entender muchos
grupos criminales han construido nexos, lazos,
conexiones, vínculos extremadamente cercanos
con muchos gobiernos e instituciones públicas
de la región. Incluso, en algunos casos estos
grupos son capaces de influir, controlar y
dirigir gobiernos enteros.
Sin ir más lejos hace muy poco, aquí en
VisualPolitik hablamos del caso de Centroamérica.
Pero, amigos, hay otro país que no podemos
pasar por alto y que en los últimos años
ha cogido la delantera hasta convertirse tal
vez en el país no en guerra más peligroso
del planeta:
Estoy hablando, por supuesto, de Venezuela.
(No es nada nuevo. Sin ir más lejos,ya os
hablamos aquí en VisualPolitik sobre cómo
Venezuela se está convirtiendo a la velocidad
del rayo en toda una narcodictadura.
Pero, desgraciadamente, ahí no queda todo.
En la Venezuela de hoy la delincuencia y el
crimen organizada campan a sus anchas hasta
tal punto que si el crimen se reduce no es
extraño pensar que es simple y llanamente
porque cada vez hay menos cosas que robar.)
[Casi 30.000 víctimas mortales que se conozcan
cada año en un país no en guerra. 130.000
muertes violentas tan solo en los últimos
5 años con datos. Que barbaridad.]
El caso es que tal y como podéis ver en pantalla
tanto la tasa de homicidios conocida como
el número de muertes violentas comenzaron
a reducirse en 2017.
Extraño teniendo en cuenta que el país está
peor que nunca tanto económica como socialmente,
¿No os parece?
Y sí, ya sé que alguno de vosotros estará
pensando… Claro, obvio eso es por toda la
emigración que ha padecido Venezuela. Más
de 4 millones de personas menos, cientos y
cientos de miles, millones de jóvenes menos
es algo que se tiene que notar.
Pues amigos, sí… y no. Con matices.
En este vídeo vamos a hablar de los efectos
que el crimen ha causado en Venezuela. Hablamos
de un crimen institucionalizado y causado
en buena medida desde el propio gobierno.
Y también os vamos a contar cómo la delincuencia
ha llegado a tales niveles que a los delincuentes
comunes ya ni siquiera les sea rentable delinquir
en Venezuela, haciendo que muchos busquen
oportunidades fuera.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Atentos.
(LOS MALOS AL PODER)
Lo primero de todo es ponerse en situación.
En un país, digamos normal, lo común es
que un gobierno combata el crimen y se dedique
a perseguir a los malos, ¿verdad?
Bueno, pues en Venezuela no es así.
Aquí nos encontramos con el fenómeno opuesto:
los malos son los que gobiernan. Fijaos.
(Tareck El Aissami: EE.UU. incluye al ministro
de Venezuela en la lista de los 10 más buscados
por narcotráfico internacional. - BBC)
(Un juez español investiga a medio gobierno
de Maduro por lavar dinero del petróleo.
- El Confidencial)
¿Sorprendidos? Apuesto a que no, sobre todos
los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo.
Seguro que habéis visto nuestro vídeo sobre
cómo Venezuela se ha convertido en un narcoestado.
[Y si aun no lo habéis visto os dejo el enlace
en la descripción]
El caso es que ya poco o nada nos puede sorprender
de este país. Sin embargo sí hay una cosa
que sigue sorprendiendonos:
Cómo el régimen chavista ha conseguido hacerse
con el monopolio de la delincuencia callejera.
(Maduro pidió ayuda a grupos afines para
"defender la paz". - El Universal)
Tal cual como lo escucháis. El gobierno venezolano
tiene literalmente a miles de delincuentes
a sueldo. Delincuentes que en muchos casos
han sido armados por el propio Estado para
que funcionen como grupos parapoliciales de
represión política.
Hablamos de los llamados colectivos.
(Los colectivos son grupos que se movilizan
a petición del gobierno, especialmente cuando
hay protestas opositoras.
Entonces se mueven con motos y armas largas
disparando a todo lo que se mueve, todo con
absoluta impunidad, mientras la policía y
la Guardia Nacional Bolivariana les miran
impasibles. Es más, en muchos casos incluso
actúan juntos.
Es decir, en otras palabras. De esta forma
es como en Venezuela la violencia ha sido
controlarla por el Estado, no para acabar
con ella sino para monopolizarla y usarla
contra los ciudadanos opositores.)
Y no, no os penseis que esto es todo.
Además de los colectivos de la muerte - que
es como se los conoce popularmente - los mismísimos
cuerpos de seguridad del Estado [Bueno, de
seguridad por decir algo] actúan como auténticos
criminales.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según los datos
aportados por la ONU casi 7.000, 7.000 personas
perdieron la vida por “resistencia a la
autoridad” entre enero de 2018 y mayo de
2019, es decir en poco más de un año. 7.000
ejecuciones extrajudiciales.
(Procesan a 464 policías en Venezuela por
delitos de extorsión y secuestro. - El Comercio)
Vamos que en Venezuela, tal y como veis, la
delincuencia está a todos los niveles. Y
eso es lo que explica que en buena parte quede
impune. Cuando hasta la polícia es en muchos
casos cómplice… mal asunto.
(92% de los homicidios que ocurren en Venezuela
quedan impunes. - El Nacional)
Y ojo, todo esto no es algo que digamos solamente
en VisualPolitik, para nada. Es algo que incluso
también afirma la mismísima Michelle Bachelet,
la alta comisionada de la ONU para los Derechos
Humanos en su informe sobre Venezuela.
(“Mi oficina ha seguido documentando casos
de posibles ejecuciones extrajudiciales cometidas
por miembros de las Fuerzas de Acción Especiales
de la Policía Nacional” (FAES). “Tan
solo en el pasado mes de julio la organización
no-gubernamental ‘Monitor de Víctimas’
identificó 57 nuevos casos de presuntas ejecuciones
cometidas por miembros del FAES en Caracas”
Michale Bachellet)
Y desde luego no creo que me podais decir,
por mucho que diga Maduro, que Bachellet forma
parte de algún movimiento internacional que
tiene como objetivo perseguir tendenciosamente
al régimen bolivariano, ¿Verdad?
Conociendo a Bachellet sería absurdo pensarlo.
Y teniendo en cuenta la situación en Venezuela,
los testimonios y la información disponible
yo personalmente creo que se quedó corta,
lo que tampoco me sorprende dicho sea de paso.
El caso es que esto no es todo.
(Junto a
los colectivos y las reprobables actuaciones
de los cuerpos de seguridad del estado, lo
cierto es que la situación en Venezuela ha
multiplicado también los delitos a pequeña
escala, la que podríamos denominar delincuencia
por arrastre o incluso delincuencia por supervivencia.
Y todo ello por no hablar de la corrupción
absolutamente generalizada que reina en el
país. En la Venezuela de hoy para conseguir
documentos oficiales, pasaportes o incluso
para lograr atención médica los sobornos
son indispensables.)(
Y es que claro, esto es algo que tiene fundamentalmente
dos razones:
Por un lado tenemos la pobreza y los salarios
que prácticamente no sirven para nada. La
hiperinflación ha hecho que los salarios
locales no alcancen para nada.
(El nuevo salario mínimo en Venezuela solo
alcanza para comprar un cartón de huevos.
- VOA)
Y claro, cuando la necesidad aprieta, la gente
se aprovecha para intentar rascar algo de
dinero como sea, aprovechándose del descontrol
y la impunidad.
Ahora bien, algunos me diréis… ¡pero Enrique!
¿No habías dicho antes que los crímenes
y la delincuencia estaban bajando? Con este
panorama no lo parece, ¿verdad?
Pues fijaos, parece complicado, pero lo cierto
es que lo está haciendo, y os vamos a contar
por qué.
Atentos porque vienen curvas.
(¿POR QUÉ SER MALANDRO HA DEJADO DE SER
RENTABLE?)
Amigos, es la triste pero cruda realidad venezolana.
Las cosas están tan mal que la crisis ha
afectado incluso a los delincuentes, o malandros
como se les conoce en Venezuela.
(Tasa de homicidios baja en Venezuela en 2018,
en parte por la masiva emigración: ONG. - Reuters)
(Crisis en Venezuela baja robos y asaltos;
delincuentes ya no pueden pagar las balas.-
El Universal)
Lo habéis escuchado bien. Pensadlo un momento.
Con una inflación del 200.000%, que es la
que pronostica el FMI para este año, ¿de
qué sirve robar minucias si el valor del
dinero que vas a poder conseguir se va a esfumar
en apenas unos días?
¿De qué sirve atracar un banco si los bolívares
que hay dentro no valen nada? ¿O de qué
sirve robar coches o motos ni es muy difícil
conseguir recambios?
Y si a todo esto le añadimos el factor emigración,
pues… la ecuación está resuelta.
Sí, parece surrealista y difícil de creer,
pero el desastre al que Nicolás Maduro está
conduciendo a Venezuela está haciendo que
miles y miles de delincuentes busquen nuevos
lugares dónde delinquir.
Por así decirlo Venezuela está exportando
su propia delincuencia.
(Maduro impulsa la salida de criminales de
Venezuela. - Panam Post)
¿Y sabéis quiénes son las principales víctimas
de esto? Sí, vale, la gente de los países
receptores pero, pensad un momento en los
otros 3 millones de venezolanos que han emigrado.
Aquí en VisualPolitik no podemos dejar pasar
por alto los efectos que este fenómeno está
teniendo en los emigrantes venezolanos en
el resto de Latinoamérica.
Porque si dejar atrás tu país, a tu familia
y todo lo que has conseguido es ya de por
sí traumático, lo que viene a continuación
lo es todavía más.
Fijaos.
(LA DIFÍCIL CONDICIÓN DE SER VENEZOLANO
EN LATINOAMÉRICA)
Así es, amigos.
Para muchos ser venezolano se ha convertido
en todo un reto en algunos países latinoamericanos.
¿Os imagináis lo que es tener que soportar
constantes comentarios racistas o xenófobos?
¿O sufrir abusos por parte de las autoridades
solo por ser de un país en concreto?
Pues todo esto forma parte del efecto que
está teniendo la salida de delincuentes venezolanos
hacia los países vecinos.
De esta forma las vidas de muchos emigrantes
venezolanos que cumplen las normas - la inmensa
mayoría - se están haciendo más difíciles
por su culpa.
Y eso es lo que provoca cosas como estas:
(Trabas burocráticas y ataques xenófobos
contra venezolanos en América Latina. - France
24)
En Perú, por ejemplo, recientemente hemos
visto incluso a congresistas, como Esther
Saavedra, atacando duramente a los venezolanos
desde el Congreso.
("Un millón de inmigrantes entre legales
e ilegales, entre trabajadores y bandidos
delincuentes, tienen que comer, tienen que
dormir, vienen a quitarles trabajo a nuestros
peruanos. (…) Venezolanos, malos o buenos
tienen que salir del Perú, que se vayan".
Esther Saavedra.)
¿Os imagináis huir de una dictadura, del
hambre y la violencia, y recibir semejantes
insultos por parte de representantes públicos?
Debe ser duro, ¿no creéis?
Claro que afortunadamente esta forma de pensar
no representa la de todos los peruanos, pero
los discursos de odio que señalan a una nacionalidad
son siempre preocupantes.
Y que se lancen desde el Congreso de un país,
lo es más aún.
Y esperad porque esto no se acaba aquí...
Hasta el propio presidente de Ecuador, Lenín
Moreno, cayó en las garras de esta campaña
tras el asesinato de una mujer embarazada
por parte de un venezolano.
(Ecuador anuncia la creación de brigadas
para "controlar" a los inmigrantes venezolanos.-
Europa Press)
Ahora bien, ¿realmente por qué en Latinoamérica
se ha generado esta oleada de odio a los venezolanos?
Pues en buena medida tiene que ver con la
falta de cultura migratoria. Tradicionalmente
la mayoría de estos países no han sido receptores
de migración y de repente, de la noche a
la mañana, se produce un éxodo de venezolanos
por todo el continente.
No parece descabellado que sean muchos los
que perciban este movimiento con miedo, miedo
a lo diferente, a lo que viene de fuera y
a las consecuencias que pueda tener, ¿no
creeis?
Y esto es algo que está pasando incluso en
Colombia:
(El país vecino de Venezuela ha sido quien
más venezolanos ha acogido, más de millón
y medio, desde la explosión de la gran crisis
venezolana entre 2014 y 2015.
La proximidad y el hecho de que emigrar de
Venezuela a Colombia sea lo más barato, ha
hecho que muchos delincuentes comunes venezolanos
acaben actuando en Colombia.
Desde un primer momento, la actitud del gobierno
colombiano ha sido la de ayudar a la población
venezolana abriendo la frontera, otorgando
permisos temporales y aceptando a venezolanos
con pasaportes caducados [bien ahí, Santos
y Duque.].
Sin embargo, esta ola de solidaridad a nivel
institucional no siempre se ha replicado al
nivel de la calle, en la vida cotidiana, ya
que Colombia se encuentra junto con Perú,
México, Chile y Ecuador, entre los países
donde más casos de xenofobia se denuncian
por parte de venezolanos.)
Y cuando nos referimos a xenofobia hablamos
de cosas que están empezando a surgir como
esta:
(Denuncian amenazas en panfletos contra inmigrantes
venezolanos en Colombia. - CNN Español)
Por supuesto esta no es ni mucho menos la
tónica mayoritaria y si algo han demostrado
las sociedades latinoamericanas es una enorme
solidaridad al acoger a miles y miles, cientos
de miles de venezolanos se que se han visto
obligados a huir de su país.
Hay que perseguir a los delincuentes pero
no sería justo que pagueren inocentes por
pecadores, ¿No os parece?
Además que ese tipo de brotes xenófobos
favorecen a la narcodictadura venezolana en
tanto en cuanto pueden llegar a reducir la
presión sobre el régimen.
En fin, amigos, esta es la realidad de la
violencia en Venezuela y todos estos factores
son los que explican que este país se haya
conver
Pero llegados a este punto turno para ti:
¿Se puede luchar contra la violencia en un
país gobernado por personas que ordenan a
criminales a matar? ¿Deben los venezolanos
en el exterior enfrentarse a sus compatriotas
malandros para acabar con la xenofobia?
Y todavía más importante, ¿creéis que
están justificados esos comportamientos de
odio contra todos ellos?
Nuestras son las preguntas, vuestras las respuestas.
Muchas gracias por ver este vídeo y, recuerda,
si te ha gustado, no olvides darle like y
suscribirte al canal. Muchos más contenidos
super interesantes están por llegar.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.